Donald Trump recently made a major
threat to North Korea during an event
held presumably between rounds of golf
at his Golf Club in New Jersey
here is the threat that Donald Trump
made once again as a reminder in case
you missed it yesterday North Korea best
not make any more threats to the United
States they will be met with fire and
fury sight like the world has never seen
he has been very threatening beyond a
normal statement and as I said they will
be met with fire fury and frankly power
the likes of which this world has never
seen before thank you thank you
so one question was what kind of force
would be unprecedented since after all
we've dropped nuclear bombs on Japan
twice that was one question we had
yesterday after learning about Donald
Trump's statement another question about
the statement was is this an official
statement of the White House's position
on North Korea is it a formal threat who
was consulted about taking this line or
did Trump just sort of come up with the
spur of the moment and we've now learned
that this was totally improvised on the
spot by Donald Trump and there were
questions about whether he had a piece
of paper in front of him when he was you
know talking about this and there were
questions like maybe this was a prepared
statement about North Korea no yet
talked about with his generals or
whoever else might be and and that was
the paper on the table in front of him
that paper apparently had opioid-related
talking points on it think about that
for a second it looks like Donald Trump
was delivering North Korean talking
points that the administration was on
board with and might have been on the
paper in front of him and the reality is
the paper had nothing to do with North
Korea this was just Donald Trump issuing
one of these erratic and escalating
threats completely off-the-cuff with no
seeming connection to the reality that
we're talking about tens or hundreds or
even hundreds of thousands or even
millions of people's lives here I
thought it was pretty obvious that it
was ad-lib though I mean one that's sort
of his style but also if you look at his
sentences there the second sentence is
pretty much a repeat of the first maybe
he of the same words he gets
well he gets memos it's two to three
bullet points and a picture on one page
maybe it's the same bullet point two or
three times right that would that could
have explained why he repeated the same
line twice seemingly not though
seemingly not we're talking about a
dangerous individual here right a total
megalomaniac loose cannon and it's yet
more evidence that what he said was not
planned or representative of the
American diplomatic position on North
Korea which we kind of had a sense of
because Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
immediately after Trump did this within
hours I believe it was he tried to calm
the situation down and sort of assured
Americans listen you can sleep at night
there's not an imminent war here and
this is where it gets even scarier
because of the haphazard nature of
Donald Trump's public comments
apparently just before this event
someone told Trump about a Washington
Post article that said hey North Korea
is making some progress miniaturizing
nuclear warheads so that we could put so
that they could put them on top of
ballistic missiles and Trump seemingly
was riled up because of that and he
issued this off-the-cuff threat to North
Korea this is a 71 year old man who's
president of the United States who
doesn't even have the self-control to
avoid reacting erratically because of
something someone whispers into his ear
before a camera shows up in front of
them I really wonder if he knew that
this threat would be heard around the
world and would be this top story
everywhere on the front of every
newspapers have maybe though I think if
it was more prepared he certainly would
have his generals around him because
Miley and Conway and Tom Price aren't
the best height people I wish you know
when during this video as Trump starts
talking about unprecedented fire and
fury the camera zooms in and you can no
longer see the look on Melania Trump's
face nor on Kellyanne Conway's face who
is sitting I think on the other side of
Tom Price as you indicated there I would
love to have seen the looks on their
face because the more than likely they
would have been completely unreactive
but that lack of reaction is what
would've been fascinating to see in the
video there might be of like the
subservience supporters in a rap battle
and he's the head honcho and they're
just sort of in the background there to
to sort of hide either for emotional
support
type it up the other possibility was we
found out recently how Trump gets a
twice daily propaganda file of positive
things about him like printed tweets and
printed screenshots from television
maybe he needed some new images of
himself on TV quote appearing strong for
his own propaganda briefing and thus he
thought hey here's an ideal threaten
North Korea next time they put a camera
in front of me the biggest concern for
me is that you've got to erratic
megalomaniacs in Trump and Kim jong-un
and you've got a president who is almost
exclusively concerned with rescuing his
failing administration that has
accomplished nothing and this escalation
with North Korea is exactly what he
might see as accomplishing that goal
send me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at
D Pakman we'll take a break and be back
after this movement is once again
sponsoring today's episode of the David
Pakman show usually I'm talking to you
about movement watches like the one I'm
wearing and have been for a while now
and they have now added sunglasses to
the repertoire they were tired of having
to pay for a lot of these really cheaply
made throwaway shades or the really
overpriced designer sunglasses so they
decided to do it themselves make their
own starting at just 74 about a month
now they're absolutely fantastic and
it's amazing because much like with the
watch wherever I go as I told you before
I checked in at my dentist's office a
month and a half ago or so and I'm just
telling them my name and they're looking
at my watch and saying what kind of a
watch is that same thing happens with
the sunglasses people like them really
really good looking pairs of sunglasses
started just 70 bucks you can upgrade to
polarized lenses if you want you could
easily pay over two hundred dollars from
one of those designer brands and much
like with their watches they are cutting
out the middleman selling directly to
the consumer online and saving you money
as a result you can also save even more
money 15% off with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t-dot-com
slash Pakman that's MVM t-dot-com slash
PA KMA and save 15%